so we just finished up the game awards
were here above where they were holding
them here in planet hollywood just below
us and one of the cool things that we
saw the show was Keith Kiefer Sutherland
he came out to introduce Metal Gear
Solid online we knew that this
announcement was going to come yes
because he'd been teasing that for a
while but for this is the first thing
we've gotten to see the multiplayer from
Metal Gear Solid online exactly Mel
you're saddled online at first people
weren't sure if this was just going to
be a separate game just going to be like
an afterthought when we solved but the
first time was team vs team multiplayer
we saw at people being able to choose
their loads being able to choose what
tactics they employ in fighting a team
of other human players which is so crazy
because Metal Gear Solid has forever
been me trying to figure out the systems
the AI systems like infiltrating a base
or taking down a boss so it's it's it's
really interesting to see it from a you
know amano amano kind of standpoint I
mean it changes up the whole way that
you you approach metal gear when you're
going up against real human opponents
but they also change up the way that
some of the items and that the things
that you interact with in the world that
those would react to yourself yeah that
so they I guess the purpose of the
trailer was to show off some of the
different ways you can even trait the
base or you could have attack another
team so they had was this for instance
the sort of radar beacon which you could
throw in that rolled in that gave you
ping sort of where those opposition
players were and there was somebody
hanging back using their binoculars to
sort of scat edge where opposition
players were there were cute dogs which
I guess worked like the third born the
porno mags medgar solid too and I guess
the sort of are we calling it the porno
box from the old metal gear solid 5
trailer is sort of us the porno box yet
it works like the porno box and what I
love the bad it is that it shows that
really interesting like evolving
gameplay that happens which doesn't
happen very often multiplayer shooters
it's usually whoever shoots first wins
but in this there was you know
mechanisms to allow people to have our
hands like for instance this big bipedal
turret terms of these arts next right
like it's burning through people and it
just so happens that
a big boss snake within this trailer is
behind the mech stop the dude takes over
it himself and then it's just laying
waste to absolutely everything including
another snake who is in cardboard box
and then of course it all culminates a
rocket comes out of nowhere I explodes
it he falls out and who is standing at
the other end of that but also Losh I'm
a metal gear fan I'm not as big a
megaphone as save Peter brand in the
office back in San Francisco and but I
think people who are big Metal Gear fans
people like me who have played a lot of
the games that are interested in our
franchise and I also think the people
who maybe don't play metal gear solid at
all but like online tutors I think this
may be something here to address a lot
of people and especially when you see
that world and it's just such a
beautiful looking game like it looks
really good i'm not a huge metal gear
fan but oh my god i want to play that so
much yes and hopefully we won't have to
wait too much longer they haven't put a
specific date on it just yet but fingers
cross will be able to play metal gear
online sometime in 2050
you